we're coming to you tonight from Los
Angeles in the sanctuary state of
beautiful California its Ground Zero in
the showdown over illegal immigration
the San Francisco Chronicle reporting
that Immigration and Customs Enforcement
is about to launch massive immigration
raids across Northern California the
raids would target criminals and those
already slated for deportation but local
police departments are reportedly not
planning to cooperate with the feds so
let's go straight to the source or maybe
the target Immigration and Customs
Enforcement director Tom Holman joins us
from Fredericksburg Virginia
director Holman thank you so much for
joining it us tonight here in California
we are at ground zero for the illegal
immigration battles
and your agency the immigration Customs
Enforcement has said that you're going
to be carrying out immigration raids in
Northern California soon and no big
surprise some of the Democrats are not
happy about that Dianne Feinstein and
Camilla Harris the two senators from
California just wrote you a letter and
they said diverting resources in an
effort to punish California and score
political points is an abhorrent abuse
of power not to mention a terrible
misuse of scarce resources sir how do
you respond well first of all ice didn't
announce any operation we certainly
don't announce operations in advance of
that it'd be an officer safety issue
what I did say is we're going to
increase resources in the state of
California in response to the sanctuary
city policies they pass and let me
explain this this isn't a threat to
California this isn't a retaliation for
sanctuary city laws we used to have
access to the jail so one officer can
sit in a gentle process ten illegal
criminal aliens in a shift
Scizor release them to the street every
that requires me to have more resources
to locate these people out in the
community and also for also safety
reasons in a county jail they don't
access the weapons we have to locate
these people on the streets in their
homes in their place of business where
them access to knowledge about what
weapons we need more officers are there
to do that job safely so adding resource
which I said I'm going to do
and resources in law enforcement option
state of California is in direct
response to the same swearing laws that
forced me in that position as far as the
congressman that wrote the letter but
let me say this while the congressmen
wrote the letter I didn't think the
Congress is in the business of enacting
laws they didn't want law enforcement to
enforce I'm enforcing the laws that
Congress enacted and for them to say
that I should be enforcing the laws
there would be no integrity and entire
system I were simply law enforcement
agency that's taken a sworn duty and the
force laws in this country we enforce
the laws that Congress enacted both of
those congressmen sit on this sit on the
legislative panel I'm doing what they
tell me to do I'm doing I'm enforcing
laws that they've enacted I'm enforcing
laws that the President signed now the
Attorney General Xavier Becerra has said
that they may take enforcement action
guess guess what against employers who
assist ice in finding these individuals
or giving information to ice about known
illegal immigrants so the state might
actually go after employers for working
with the federal government and they
cite their protection of immigrant act
which passed and was signed into law
went into effect January 1st of this
year because they will be then I guess
intruding on the privacy of the illegal
immigrants so this is what you're up
against you're up against these state
officials who are threatening local
essentially local law enforcement or
employers director Holman look if he's
the Attorney General he certainly knows
what the law says we are enforcing the
laws enacted by Congress and you know is
there any other federal law enforcement
agency state and local agency where
congressman or election officials or
Attorney General's they do not enforce
the law no one asks FBI not enforce law
or DEA or ATF or the local police
departments we're clearly enforcing the
laws enacted by Congress and let me say
this for those that say they don't give
us access to these low-level criminals
in county jails the local police
department arrested these people they
locked them up in their in their
facilities these
these aren't choirboys these are people
who have been arrested for crimes and
sit in a County Jail yeah well speaking
of people have been arrested and
deported that horrific story from a few
years ago we had two police officers
brutally murdered by an illegal
immigrant Louise bracamontes who killed
these police officers and he had been
deported several times we have a
soundbite we're gonna play it of what he
said recently when he appeared in court
let's watch so you see what he says he
said basically I killed them they're
dead and if I could I'd kill more this
is these this is what the fallout is of
this sanctuary State wide policy that's
in effect and then we have other
examples individuals who stabbed sixty
one-year-old who's also been deported
and you never hear about these people
from the Attorney General or these other
officials like Jerry Brown who are
always lobbying for more frankly open
borders policies well look again you
know these sanctuary city policies it's
a clear public safety threat releasing a
public safety threat back into the
public it's just bad policy and I say it
again they're in a County Jail they've
been arrested by the local officials
they're sitting in a Cell so apparently
they thought they're a danger to
community when they're done with them
why not let the federal law force they
see in charge of enforcing law take
custody these people not only remove
them from the community removed from the
country so that I remember when you
enter this country you commit a crime
but enter this country legally right now
it's a right of universal right very
quickly the the local mayor of Oakland
Libby Schaaf has told reporters that her
police in her city are not going to
assist you in any upcoming enforcement
actions a quick message to her so let me
let me speak not to her because I
certainly don't respect her opinion I
don't respect what they did I mean let
me say this that
to the men and women the Oakland Police
Department I know first why I'm sad
you're putting input in position at a
politician who's narak it never carried
a gun and badge and never put their life
on the line every day like you did makes
these type of decisions that affect
Public Safety and officer safety but
I'll give you this commitment from ice
if you're all there doing a lawful
operation and you are in need of
assistance if you find yourself in
trouble and there's an ice agent when
the ears shy or in an area we will do
everything we can with our legal
authority to assist you we will do
everything we can to make sure you go
home safe that night to your families we
will never turn our back on law
enforcement ice has your six